[Applause]
[Music]
we're halfway through November and even
though the temperature is dropping in
some parts of the world the video game
releases definitely aren't slowing down
in the cold hell half of this week's new
releases are going to space or traveling
to different dimensions let's take a
ride our first stop is in a galaxy far
far away
no matter which Star Wars era you grew
up with Star Wars Battlefront 2 who
covers at all maps draw from the
original prequel and sequel trilogy z'
with a brand new single-player story
mode featuring original characters and
all future maps and heroes will be free
to download let's not forget the large
scale space ship battles either you can
strap in and take off into those on ps4
Xbox one and PC on Friday November 17th
or a few days earlier on the 14th if
you've purchased the deluxe edition and
if you want to see the game in action
even earlier we've got plenty of
gameplay for you to check out from a
full match on Kashyyyk to a bunch of
multiplayer maps that haven't even been
shown yet you can also get galactic
earlier in the week with Lego Marvel
Super Heroes 2 this sequel ups the
minifigure ante the only way it can with
a collision of multiple Marvel
Universe's you'll be able to explore a
bunch of different worlds like a noir
version of New York nowhere and an
alternate medieval timeline as you chase
after Kang the Conqueror with colliding
worlds comes all sorts of crazy
characters - including combinations like
iron duck that's that's how are the Duck
Plus Ironman yeah in any case you can
start building on ps4 Xbox one PC and
Nintendo switch on Tuesday the 14th
Legos are for the whole family but LA
noire is definitely not the like
catching crime solving game is coming to
the current generation with some big
improvements this rerelease includes the
full version of the game all the DLC
cases better textures and lighting new
cinematic camera angles and 4k support
on Xbox one and ps4 pro as for the
switch version you can
with new gesture-based joy kaan controls
and special touch based controls for
portable mode just make sure you have a
big enough SD card if you go the digital
route since it's too big for the
switches internal storage as is la Noir
comes to all of those platforms on the
14th but Nintendo platforms are also
getting more family-friendly games this
week pokemon ultra son and ultra moon
are enhanced versions of last year's 3d
s adventures with you guessed it some
additional Pokemon and new features on
top of some new ultra beasts and Z moves
you'll also be able to surf between a
lola's islands pose alongside Pokemon
when taking photos and even go through
wormholes to meet the beasts in their
own world you can catch them all again
on Friday the 17th it's just a shame
this version doesn't include Danny
DeVito now back to the switch and the
not so kid-friendly stuff
Skyrim is making its way to Nintendo's
portable platform letting you take the
dragon slaying RPG anywhere and you can
even tap certain amiibo figures to
unlock links outfit and equipment
gesture controls are here too thanks to
the joy cons but that's not the only new
way to play you can also swing some move
controllers with Skyrim's VR version
coming to psvr the same day both of
these include the base game and all
expansions and you can dig into all that
good stuff on the 17th and those are
some of the hottest games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings at are subject to change thanks
for watching guys and I'll be back with
more new releases next Sunday